MacKINNON, MISSED THE CALGARY
GAME HE'S GOING TO CREASE.GO BY
A SAN JOSE PLAYER.HE YOUNG
DEFENSE BACK TO MacKINNON.
SHOT WENT OFF A ABLE TO DIAND TN
GOAL.
TRADED BEFORE, I HAVE NEVER HAD
TO LEARN A UP IN SAVE BY KAHKON.
HE SAID IT'S TAKING A
SCORES!
[ HORN ]BURST.HE HAD A BETTERTE,
IT WAS DETERMINED THAT THERE WA.
RANTANEN GIVES IT OFF TO THE MA,
RANTANEN, THE LEFT-
REALLY NICE JOBITING.
THEY ARE A LITTLE GOOD IT'S NOTM
DURING THAT INTERVIEW, J.T.
COMPHER RANG IT OFF.
ALEXANDER BARBANOV GOES ALL THE
WAY TO THE FRONT AND CAN'T OFF D
OUT IT JOSE LATE IN THE -- ON TE
G UP ON THE
A MATTER OF FACT, AN EIGHT -- AN
$8 MILLION A YEAR CONTRACT FOR
EIGHT
GOALTO WHERE
CORRALS.
BALLSER TRIES TO FINDLM.
HE SCORES!
[ HORN ]
JUST A -- A
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE ANDHE CO,
THEY ARE SOMEHOW SKIPS BY TO FR.
THE AVALANCNC TOEWS.
BACK AHEAD IT'S NICHUSICHUSHKINY
LAST DEEP.
LOOSE PUCK POKED AHEAD BY LOOK .
HE'S  MOOSE GOT
LOOSE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE FAR
[ HORN ]
>> GOT THE REBOUND OFF THE PAD
OF KAHKONEN.
THAT BREAKS
THE TRAINER IS POKING AT HIS
SHOULDER.
HE COMES DOWN THE ICE.